okay now we arrive at question three and
here's where it starts to get a little
more interesting so the area is pretty
straightforward I've just named these
area one area two area three for the
triangle rectangle and triangle and I've
given you there's there's actually no
further calculation required unlike
saying this one where you at least had
to have this diameter here there's no
further calculation required because for
the triangles you've got the height the
perpendicular height and its base for
the rectangle you've got its uh length
and sorry it's breadth and its length
just here and then for this triangle
down here again you've got height
perpendicular height and the base is
consistent with the first triangle so
when you're working out the area
this is how it all pans out and you'll
get that number in a fairly
straightforward way
but then you come to the perimeter and
suddenly you think hold on a second how
am I going to work out the perimeter
because in fact and this was part of
what I wanted my students to kind of uh
encounter and stumble upon as they went
through this question there is
insufficient information on this diagram
to conclusively and unambiguously
determine what the perimeter is now that
doesn't mean you can't work out anything
as you're going to see I will give you
um I I think you can work through this
problem in a meaningful way and that's
what the question that I post to my
students back all those years ago ended
up being but as for there just being one
right answer there isn't one there isn't
just one perimeter that this shape can
have and I'm going to prove it
so the issue here is that say for
example points X and Y you know that
they are respectively two meters above
this base and then four meters below uh
this length over here QR you know what
that vertical distance is but what you
don't know is where X is positioned
horizontally so for example same thing
with Y as well so for example if I were
to say let's let's put in some
horizontal uh lines in here so I'll put
one there
and I'll do one here for good measure
and now if we were to draw I'm calling
it PSX at the moment so if I go across
oops let's see if I can do that a bit
more accurately and see if that'll lock
in perfect okay there we go so here's
how roughly speaking uh PSX looks at the
moment and I hope you can agree that's I
mean it's not perfect I can make that a
little bit more accurate but there you
go hopefully you're content that that's
a representation of where X is at the
moment but retaining the fact that I've
got this uh two meter height up here
this perpendicular height there's no
reason why I can't take the point x and
just move it somewhere else right I can
change that X and all of the
measurements that were provided in the
original question will still be true but
the perimeter might not be the same the
length for uh p x s in the original
might be different to this p x s and
what you can see here is that based on
where I position X there's lots of
different values that the the perimeter
of just P X Plus x s and then you
include that in the whole thing is going
to be so to actually prove like not just
eyeball and say oh it looks about it
looks like it's going to change we can
actually prove that things are going to
be different by considering a couple of
different cases so the first one I'm
going to consider is what if we moved X
all the way over I think I can do that
about right that looks like a vertical
line to me so what you've got here is if
I position X directly above Point P
right now you can see you end up with
this right angle triangle here and it
would be the same right angled triangle
just flipped over if I would position X
over on the other side above s instead
of above P so I'm just going to consider
that one case and then see what we end
up with
so let's go ahead I might just grab this
over here
bring it down here
that'll do
now what do I know about this thing well
I did call it what did we say PSX so P's
here s is here x is there I positioned X
directly above P so I've got a right
angle and I think we said that that's
two meters and from memory this is 10.5
meters
okay now we're going to call this case
one
and for case one because I've created
this right angled triangle just like in
an earlier question I can use Pythagoras
now I'm just going to skip along a
little bit and I'm going to say that x s
rather than just saying it's the square
of the hypotenuse blah blah blah I'm
just going to scroll straight to this
next line and say it's the square root
of the sum of the squares of the two
shorter sides which in this case is 2
squared
plus 10.5 squared and take the square
root now I've gone ahead and I've
already evaluated what that is that's
10.69 centimeters approximately and that
gives me this length over here but then
I also need PX because PX is part of the
original shape here we want PX and SX so
I've got both of them right so therefore
I can say
in this case P X Plus x s is going to be
the 10.69 Plus in this case it's just
two I've already got that measurement so
that of course is just going to give me
12.69 centimeters all right so this case
one but X can be in other places I can
move it along as we demonstrated before
now the particular version that I want
to compare is case 2 is what if I put X
right smack bang I'm going to try and
Eyeball this there we go uh yeah that'll
do what if I position X right directly
in the middle
um over the midpoint of p s so this is
going to be a different case and I'll
prove it to you by actually doing the
calculations so if we put I'll put it
there
our new p s and X this length here the
perpendicular height is still 2 meters
but now to work out PX and s x I'm going
to have to use Pythagoras just with
different lengths right because I've got
a new right angle triangle here and the
relevant side length underneath here is
not 10.5 it's half of that so it's
5.25 which is an awkward number which I
would not have designed if I'd been a
little more thoughtful about making the
numbers neater okay but this is case two
let's now think about what uh let's just
go with calculating XS again because
that's what I did before
x s is still going to be it's still the
hypotenuse of a triangle and it's going
to have that 2 squared is still the same
but now the other length is just the
5.25 it's just halfway across right so
let's go
5.25 or squared now again you can reach
for your calculator and hopefully you
can verify that that's about
5.62 centimeters and now just like
before
I need not just uh not just XS but also
PX so in this case Xs and PX are
identical because I created a
symmetrical triangle here it's isosceles
right so therefore I can just take that
and I can double it so I can say PX plus
x s is going to be that's still
approximate because I've I've doubled
that that's going to be
11.24 centimeters
all right now have a think about this
for a moment right what I've just shown
is that depending on where you position
X you can have um a variety of different
lengths right you can have 12.69 if you
position X on one of the extremities
right and in fact I suppose I could have
even said like you know what if x could
have gone all the way over here well
that's not a case I'm going to consider
because I can clearly see X is somewhere
between P and S I've got this link here
this seems to be the longest it can
possibly be under this configuration and
then I've got uh this configuration if
I've got X right in the middle there and
this is a shorter length so I suppose
you could say this is a maximum and this
is a minimum now you can go ahead and
you can apply the same logic remember
how I did this up the top here right
well you can do the same thing for y you
can move it horizontally as well so if I
do this neatly not like that
let's see all right snap into place
there you go well done all right in much
the same way I can position from y
directly beneath Q if I positioned it
directly beneath R it'll be the same
theme or I can position it somewhere in
the middle and what you'll find is let's
put it on let's put on one side why not
what you will find is when you consider
triangle r q y uh for
see
triangle r q y you end up having
different minimum and maximum length
because this triangle is twice as tall
so you're going to have the same 5.25
that you saw before but this will be
four now right so when I go ahead and I
do that it's going to be double because
I'm going to get this side and this side
and it's the square root of 4 squared
plus
5.25 squared
let's grab the calculator and punch that
in square root that'll be 16. I don't
know what 5.25 squared is off the top of
my head so that's going to be
13.20 yes that rings a bell and the
maximum
is
15.27 centimeters and you can go ahead
and you can test that out using this
right angle triangle version of it right
so even though I don't have a firm fix
on what the actual length is I can know
that the the lowest it can possibly be
all the way around is going to be this
length here this minimum plus this
minimum that gives me my top and bottom
as it were plus four for the two sides
here and then my maximum is going to be
this length plus this length plus the
four again so what I can say is
once you do all of the uh all of that
number to crunching
um the perimeter is going to be within
this range so if you take all of those
lengths there and this will be inclusive
in fact it's going to be
28.44 centimeters on the bottom and then
let's just do the maximum and verify it
so I don't lock up my numbers 12.69 plus
15.27 plus the 4. yeah happy times 31.96
centimeters Okay so
you can see here the point behind this
question is sometimes you actually need
to have a range for something right in
reality we encounter all kinds of
measurements where there is some kind of
uncertainty and that doesn't mean you
can't do any calculation right like this
is still actually a reasonably small
range if for instance you wanted to have
the amount of fence that went all around
the edges of this unusual shaped Paddock
right if you were fencing this even
though you might not have known where X
and Y were precisely you can know still
that you're going to have somewhere
between you know 28 and 32 centimeters
meters if you had a paddock I guess
would be different units and that amount
of error I think is quite acceptable
right so hopefully that makes sense of
this question if you felt like oh there
wasn't sufficient information there
wasn't to get a precise answer but there
still is to get a reasonable answer